When I sat down to interview this guy, Bill Tobin, he made this request that I don't think anybody's ever made with me in all the years that I've been recording interviews for the radio..
当我坐下来采访这个人，比尔·托宾（Bill Tobin）时，他提出了一个请求，我想在我录制广播采访的这些年里，从来没有人向我提出过这样的要求……
You can cut out the dead air time, right? I have a courtroom style and deposition style that, when you live and die by the words that come out of your mouth, I want to make sure I try to select the most appropriate phrase. So I have a tendency to be a-- my wife tells me, you're not in the courtroom. Your speech is too deliberate and too slow. But anyway, you can edit out.
你可以剪掉那些冷场的时间，对吧？我习惯了法庭和证词陈述那种说话风格，当你必须对从嘴里说出的每一个字负责时，我会想确保我选用的措辞是最恰当的。所以我有一种倾向——我妻子告诉我，你现在不在法庭上。你的语速太刻意、太慢了。但不管怎样，你可以剪掉这些。
Yeah, we'll edit out the pauses, yeah. Your wife will love you. When we are done with this, she'll be like--
是的，我们会剪掉停顿。你妻子会喜欢你的。当我们做完这一切，她会觉得——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
All right.
好的。
Bill's a former FBI agent. And back in the early 1970s, he was investigating organized crime and police corruption in Chicago for the FBI. A cop told them how it worked at the time. This cop said that, when he was a rookie, just coming on the force--
比尔是一位前联邦调查局探员。在20世纪70年代初，他在芝加哥为联邦调查局调查有组织犯罪和警察腐败。一位警察告诉他们当时的情况是如何运作的。这位警察说，当他还是个刚入职的菜鸟时——
He was taken by his TO around the city-- and TO being a training officer-- and he expressed surprise that they were hitting all of the bowling alleys in their district and other businesses that had liquor licenses. And he was kind of confused, with all the crime in the city, why they were stopping at bowling alleys.
他的带教警官（TO，即训练官）带着他在城里转——他表示很惊讶，因为他们扫荡了辖区内所有的保龄球馆和其他有酒类执照的企业。他当时有点困惑，城里有那么多犯罪，为什么偏偏停在保龄球馆。
But he said after they hit a number of them, he was handed a white envelope by his training officer, and he said, here's yours. And he said he opened it up and there was this wad of money inside. And he said a light went off, and he kind of said, well, thanks but no thanks. I don't want to participate in this. This is not my bag, but you don't have to worry about me. I'm not going to blow the whistle or dime anybody.
但他说，在他们扫荡了几家之后，他的训练官递给他一个白信封，说：“这是你的。”他说他打开信封，里面有一叠钱。他说他恍然大悟，然后说：“好吧，谢谢，但我还是不要了。我不想参与其中。这不是我的风格，但你不用担心我。我不会去举报，也不会向任何人告密。”
So he said, when the next duty roster came out, he found himself on vertical patrol in a place called Cabrini-Green, which at the time was a high-rise housing project that was so pervasive with crimes that, for example, I remember one incident several officers were on an elevator, and residents had stopped the elevator between floors, poured gasoline down the chute, and ignited the gasoline.
所以他说，当下一份值班表出来时，他发现自己被派去一个叫卡布里尼-格林（Cabrini-Green）的地方进行“垂直巡逻”。在当时，那是一个犯罪猖獗的高层住宅区，举个例子，我记得有一次，几名警察在电梯里，居民把电梯停在楼层之间，顺着井道倒进汽油，然后点燃了汽油。
The place was so bad that they had to actually put an officer every second floor, and they called that vertical patrol. So he worked that for a number of weeks, but he said a number of weeks working vertical patrol and you just basically almost go crazy. So he says, at that point, you're willing to do almost anything. And he kind of, after that, began to accept those envelopes. And he said that was the only way he could get off vertical patrol.
那个地方实在太糟糕了，他们实际上不得不每隔一层楼就安排一名警察，他们称之为“垂直巡逻”。所以他那样工作了几周，但他表示，在垂直巡逻中工作几周后，你基本上会快要发疯了。所以他说，在那一点上，你愿意做任何事。在那之后，他开始接受那些信封。他说那是他摆脱垂直巡逻的唯一途径。
Do you have any sympathy for this guy's dilemma, with the choice he made?
你对这个人的困境以及他所做的选择有什么同情吗？
Well, to my knowledge, at the time, I would have to say the officer basically only had two choices, either change jobs or agree to go on the take. I mean, realistically or pragmatically, those are the only two choices he had.
嗯，据我所知，当时我不得不说这位警官基本上只有两个选择，要么换工作，要么同意同流合污。我的意思是，从现实或务实的角度来看，这就是他仅有的两个选择。
And if you faced that choice, you feel like that'd be clear? What to do?
如果你面临这种选择，你觉得你会很清楚该怎么做吗？
Absolutely, unequivocally. I mean, to me, police corruption is the height of dishonesty, as far as I'm concerned.
绝对，毫无疑问。我的意思是，对我而言，我认为警察腐败是极度不诚实的表现。
That's what's so insidious about this kind of old boys' network, is that it pulls in bad people and good ones also. You kind of have to take part if you want to stick around. You're with them or against them. The cop who told him this story really believed that.
这种“老男孩网络”（old boys' network）最阴险的地方在于，它既拉拢坏人，也拉拢好人。如果你想留下来，你就不得不参与其中。你要么加入他们，要么对抗他们。那个告诉他这个故事的警察对此深信不疑。
He said, you know, truth be told, the overwhelming majority of officers with whom I have interactions would do anything for you guys to be able to come in and clean house. We really don't want to be on the take, but the peer pressure is just so immense that he said you just have to go with the flow.
他说：“你知道，说实话，与我共事的绝大多数警察都愿意为你们做任何事，好让你们能进来清理门户。我们真的不想同流合污，但同伴压力实在太大了，他说你只能随波逐流。”
Do you buy that?
你相信吗？
Oh, absolutely. After one of the search warrants that we executed, during the search we recovered a list of payees, and we're showing 90%-plus of the names on the police force were on the list, who were recipients of biweekly or monthly payoffs.
哦，完全相信。在我们执行过的一次搜查令后，我们在搜查过程中找到了一份收款人名单，显示警察局里超过90%的人都在名单上，他们是双周或月度贿赂的接受者。
Well, today on our radio show, we have two stories. One is about people who do not want to go along with the old boy network. The other is about people who very obediently do go along with it. And I'm just going to, before we get these started. I'm just going to give you a moment here to guess which of these two groups of people, the ones who go along and the ones who don't go along, are now sitting judges in Chicago.
好了，今天在我们的广播节目中，我们有两个故事。一个是关于那些不想同流合污的人。另一个是关于那些非常顺从地同流合污的人。在开始之前，我要给你们一点时间来猜猜，这两群人中——那些同流合污的人和那些不妥协的人——哪一群人现在是芝加哥的在职法官。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by the sinister and all-encompassing old boys' network that is known everywhere on the seven seas and seven continents as Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
这里是WBEZ芝加哥电台的《美国生活》（This American Life），节目由那个在七大洋七大洲都被称为“公共广播国际”（Public Radio International）的邪恶且无处不在的“老男孩网络”分发。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。请继续收听。
Act One, Messing With the Bull. A little over a year ago, in a small west Texas town called Kermit, two nurses were accused of something very strange. They were accused of harassing a doctor. The harassment, basically, was that they complained to the Texas Medical Board, saying that this doctor was performing odd procedures and putting patients in danger. The nurses were fired for this, and they were arrested, and they were facing 10 years in prison.
第一幕：招惹公牛。一年多以前，在德克萨斯州西部一个小镇克米特（Kermit），两名护士被指控犯有非常奇怪的事情。她们被控骚扰一名医生。骚扰的内容基本上就是她们向德克萨斯州医学委员会投诉，称这位医生在进行奇怪的医疗程序并让病人处于危险之中。这两名护士因此被解雇，并被逮捕，面临10年监禁。
Their story made the national news. You may have heard of it. It seemed like a classic case of retribution against whistleblowers. And one reporter, Saul Elbein, looked into this. He realized that it was actually a group of powerful men in this small town who went to extreme and even ridiculous lengths to try to bring down these nurses. In particular, one nurse. Anne Mitchell. Here's the story.
她们的故事上了全国新闻。你可能听说过。这看起来像是打击举报人的典型案例。一位名叫索尔·埃尔拜因（Saul Elbein）的记者调查了这件事。他意识到，实际上是这个小镇上一群有权势的人，采取了极端甚至荒谬的手段来试图打倒这些护士。特别是其中一名护士，安妮·米切尔（Anne Mitchell）。这就是故事。
Anne Mitchell's trial took place last February. It lasted four days, and was filled with so many ridiculous moments that, by the end, it seemed like anything could happen, though Anne's attorney, John Cook, was optimistic.
安妮·米切尔的审判发生在去年二月。审判持续了四天，充满了许多荒谬的时刻，以至于到最后，似乎任何事情都有可能发生，尽管安妮的律师约翰·库克（John Cook）很乐观。
I got a sense that, we've won. We had blown them out of the water so hard. I didn't need to tell the jury why we should win. I figured they already knew. And then they stayed out for an hour, and I was hoping for a really quick verdict. So it stretched on an hour. When you're waiting for a verdict, an hour is a long time.
我有一种感觉，我们赢了。我们把他们打得落花流水，我不需要告诉陪审团为什么我们应该赢。我想他们已经知道了。然后他们休庭了一小时，我当时希望能尽快有判决结果。但时间拖了一个小时。当你等待判决时，一个小时是很长的时间。
So we're waiting, we're waiting, we're waiting. And then suddenly they said, the jury's back.
所以我们一直在等，一直在等。然后突然他们说，陪审团回来了。
This is Anne Mitchell.
这是安妮·米切尔。
And Judge Rex got the papers, and he flipped the page over, and he said, not guilty. Mrs. Mitchell, you're free to go.
雷克斯（Rex）法官拿到了文件，翻开那一页，他说：“无罪。米切尔夫人，你可以走了。”
Talking to the foreman after the trial, I said, how come it took you so long? He goes, oh, Mr. Cook, it didn't take that long. We got back there, and I said to them, does anybody think this lady did anything wrong? And everybody said, no. And he goes, well, they all worked pretty hard, so we better stay in here. We better stay in here and look like we're working, too. So we sat back there for an hour and we talked about our families. But we could have had that verdict in less than five minutes.
审判结束后我跟陪审团长交谈，我说：“怎么花了你们这么长时间？”他说：“噢，库克先生，没花那么久。我们回到后面，我对他们说，有人认为这位女士做了什么错事吗？大家都说没有。他说，嗯，他们都很努力地工作了，所以我们最好待在这里。我们最好待在这里，看起来也像是在努力工作。所以我们就在后面坐了一个小时，聊了聊我们的家人。但我们本可以在不到五分钟内做出判决。”
The absurd and disturbing events that led to this five-minute, hour-long verdict began in 2008, when Dr. Rolando Arafiles took a job at the one hospital in Kermit, Winkler County Memorial. It's tiny, just 19 beds, plus a rural health clinic for non-emergency outpatient care. And they couldn't hold on to doctors. It's hard to find anyone who wants to move there.
导致这个“五分钟、一小时”判决的荒谬和令人不安的事件始于2008年，当时罗兰多·阿拉菲尔斯（Rolando Arafiles）医生在克米特唯一的一家医院——温克勒县纪念医院（Winkler County Memorial）找了一份工作。它很小，只有19张床位，外加一个负责非急诊门诊护理的农村卫生诊所。他们留不住医生。很难找到愿意搬到那里去的人。
Kermit's a tiny, dusty oil town out in the west Texas plains, about 20 miles from the New Mexico border. It's the kind of town where tumbleweed really does roll down the main drag in the afternoons. One of the nearest towns is called Notrees. But Arafiles seemed happy to settle in Kermit. And when he first came to Winkler Memorial, former nurses and the current board president say everyone was charmed by him.
克米特是一个位于德克萨斯州西部平原的小小的、尘土飞扬的石油小镇，距离新墨西哥州边境约20英里。那是一个风滚草真的会在午后滚过大街的小镇。附近最近的小镇之一叫“无树镇”（Notrees）。但阿拉菲尔斯似乎很乐意在克米特定居。当他第一次来到温克勒纪念医院时，前护士和现任董事会主席都说大家都被他迷住了。
He's a super nice guy. He's very charismatic.
他是个超级好人。他非常有魅力。
As a person, he was very friendly, easy to get along with. I mean, he was down to earth.
作为一个人，他非常友好，容易相处。我的意思是，他很脚踏实地。
I'll tell you one thing, Dr. A. is not a bad doctor. He's a [? barstool, ?] a seamstress. You cut your head open, man, that guy can sew like crazy.
我告诉你一件事，阿拉菲尔斯医生不是个庸医，他是个高明的缝合匠。如果你脑袋被割破了，伙计，那家伙缝合的技术简直绝了。
For decades before Arafiles came, the hospital had mostly relied on foreign doctors, under something called the J-1 Visa System. They would come fresh out of medical school in places like India or Vietnam. They'd serve for three years, and then they'd move on to a bigger city. Their care was mostly good, but they were clearly just biding their time till they could leave. The hospital could only keep two to three doctors on staff at a time.
在阿拉菲尔斯来之前的几十年里，这家医院主要依靠外籍医生，即所谓的J-1签证系统。他们会刚从印度或越南等地的医学院毕业来到这里。他们服务三年，然后搬到更大的城市。他们的护理水平大部分是不错的，但很显然他们只是在等待离开的时机。医院一次只能维持两到三名医生在职。
But Dr. Arafiles had bought a house in town, and put down roots. He was a native of the Philippines, but he fit in well in Kermit. He and his wife joined the Lions Club. They sang in the choir at the Methodist church. It seemed like he was going to give this small town exactly the sort of small town doctor they'd always wanted. But pretty quickly, nurses started to get concerned.
但阿拉菲尔斯医生在镇上买了房子，扎下了根。他来自菲律宾，但在克米特适应得很好。他和妻子加入了狮子会。他们在卫理公会的唱诗班唱歌。看起来他会给这个小镇带来他们一直想要的医生。但很快，护士们开始感到担忧。
I had to go through his charts every day I worked on his side.
我每天在他负责的一侧工作时都得检查他的病历。
This is Debby Eggers, a nurse who worked directly with Arafiles.
这是黛比·埃格斯（Debby Eggers），一名直接与阿拉菲尔斯共事的护士。
I really never saw him open up a chart to go through it, to see if there's labs that had been done, to see if medications need to be increased, decreased, discontinued.
我真的没见过他打开病历去查阅，看看是否做了检查，看看是否需要增加、减少或停止某种药物。
Or if patients needed to be on medication at all. Debby says she caught one chart where he put a non-diabetic patient on insulin.
或者病人是否根本需要服药。黛比说她发现了一份病历，上面显示他给一名非糖尿病患者开了胰岛素。
It was on a day that I was working on his side, and he had signed something that, I believe it was a pharmacy OK-ing some kind of diabetic medication. We had no documentation, no labs, or anything in our chart justifying that this patient was even diabetic. When I brought it to his attention, he told me, he said, I like it when you work on my side. He said, you're my eyes. I never look at anything. I just sign my name.
那天我正好在他负责的一侧工作，他签署了一些东西，我相信是药房核准某种糖尿病药物。我们的病历中没有任何文件、化验单或任何东西证明这名病人是糖尿病患者。当我引起他的注意时，他对我说：“我喜欢你在我这边工作。他说，你是我的眼睛。我从不看任何东西。我只是签名。”
Arafiles would diagnose patients without running labs. Or if the nurses had run labs, he wouldn't look at those either. Maybe this is stating the obvious, but this is really unusual for a doctor. It's also potentially dangerous. But nurses say Arafiles had his own way of doing things. Like, for example, how he diagnosed thyroid conditions. Debby says he brought in this questionnaire. None of the medical professionals at the hospital had seen it before.
阿拉菲尔斯会在不做化验的情况下诊断病人。或者如果护士们做了化验，他也不会去看那些结果。也许这显而易见，但这对于一名医生来说是非常不寻常的。这也是潜在的危险。但护士们说阿拉菲尔斯有他自己的一套做事方式。例如，他如何诊断甲状腺疾病。黛比说他带进来一份调查问卷。医院里的医疗专业人员都没见过这个。
And there would be, like, tests to see, is your skin dry? Are you overweight? Is your hair dry? Do you get tired? Are you fatigued? Do you sleep a lot? Do you not sleep? And he would score it, and depending on your score, he would put you on thyroid medicine. I myself took the test. I mean, because we had to make copies, so of course I'm going to see what all the questions are. I'll take it myself. And yeah, I'd need medicine, because I've got all the symptoms. But my lab, it's normal.
上面会有测试，比如：你的皮肤干燥吗？你超重了吗？你的头发干枯吗？你感到累吗？你感到疲劳吗？你睡得多吗？你失眠吗？他会给这些打分，根据你的分数，他会让你服用甲状腺药物。我本人也做了测试。我的意思是，因为我们要复印，所以我当然会看看所有的问题是什么。我自己也做了测试。是的，我需要服药，因为我所有的症状都有。但我的化验结果是正常的。
Naomi Warren was another nurse who saw this happening. She ran the clinic at Winkler, and she says Arafiles was really proud of his method of diagnosing thyroid conditions. He told her, you just look for obesity, extra fat behind the arms. You don't need the labs.
娜奥米·沃伦（Naomi Warren）是另一位看到这种情况的护士。她经营着温克勒诊所，她说阿拉菲尔斯非常自豪于他诊断甲状腺疾病的方法。他告诉她：“你只要看肥胖情况，看手臂后面的多余脂肪就行了。不需要化验。”
That's not the standard. I've never read that anywhere. I told him I could not follow that type of care without some sort of a medical reference to support it. And so, he told me he would give me some references. He brought back two paperback books.
那不是标准做法。我从来没在任何地方读到过这个。我告诉他，没有某种医疗参考支持，我无法遵循那种护理方式。于是，他说他会给我一些参考资料。他带回了两本平装书。
Paperback books?
平装书？
Two paperback books that were obviously alternative medicine. Frankly, I could only stand to read, kind of look at one, because I just didn't believe any of it.
两本显然是替代医学的平装书。坦率地说，我只能忍着看其中一本，因为我根本不相信里面的任何内容。
Naomi says it's not just that he was a big believer in alternative medicine. He had no consistency. He would take people who had conditions off their medications, and put people who had no need for medications on them.
娜奥米说，不仅是因为他是一个替代医学的忠实信徒。而且他没有任何一致性。他会停止给有病的人服药，却给不需要药物的人开药。
Thyroid wasn't the only thing. He would take people many times off of their cholesterol medicine or blood pressure medicine and offer an herbal alternative.
甲状腺不是唯一的问题。他多次让病人停用降胆固醇药物或降压药，并提供草药替代品。
This really shocked nurses at the hospital. Because not only was Arafiles pushing these herbal remedies on patients, he was also selling them. One of these herbal medicines was something called Zrii, a fruit juice advertised as being based on the ancient wisdom of the Ayurveda. Nurses never saw him sell at the hospital, but it was well known that at the same time Arafiles was working in the hospital, he was holding seminars at the Kermit Pizza Hut and the Methodist church, signing people up as Zrii distributors. You sell Zrii sort of the same way you sell Tupperware or Amway. The more people you sign up to sell for you, the more money you make.
这确实让医院的护士们感到震惊。因为阿拉菲尔斯不仅在向病人推销这些草药，他还在兜售它们。其中一种草药叫Zrii，这是一种果汁，广告宣称是基于古老的阿育吠陀智慧。护士们从未见他在医院里销售，但众所周知，在阿拉菲尔斯在医院工作期间，他还在克米特的必胜客和卫理公会教堂举办研讨会，让人们注册成为Zrii经销商。你销售Zrii的方式和你销售特百惠（Tupperware）或安利（Amway）的方式差不多。你注册的人越多，你赚的钱就越多。
He had samples that he gave in the clinic.
他确实有在诊所提供的样品。
And then you'd contact him after work?
然后你下班后联系他？
Yeah. He had fliers and email alerts, and would give the patient a number to call if they wanted to order it. That kind of thing.
是的。他有传单和电子邮件提醒，如果病人想订购，他会给他们一个号码。就是那种事。
What he was doing with Zrii and the other supplements he sold wasn't exactly illegal, but it was sketchy as hell. And a violation of the hospital's policies. The nurses complained about Arafiles to the chief of staff, Dr. Pham. At that time, he was the only other doctor there. He refused to talk about it, but nurses say he was just as concerned about things Arafiles was doing. He'd bring up issues at medical board and staff meetings. Naomi Warren says that once she even heard Pham chewing out Arafiles.
他用Zrii和其他补充剂所做的事情并不完全违法，但非常可疑。而且违反了医院的政策。护士们向首席医疗官法姆（Pham）医生投诉了阿拉菲尔斯。当时，他是那里唯一的另一位医生。他拒绝谈论这件事，但护士们说他同样担心阿拉菲尔斯做的事情。他会在医疗委员会和员工会议上提出这些问题。娜奥米·沃伦说，有一次她甚至听到法姆医生在训斥阿拉菲尔斯。
There was some yelling behind closed doors. I did hear it. And Dr. Pham at one point told me, we've agreed to disagree. He'll take care of his patients. I'll take care of mine.
关起门来有一些争吵声。我确实听到了。法姆医生有一次对我说：“我们同意保留分歧。他照顾他的病人，我照顾我的病人。”
A lot of nurses took their concerns about Arafiles to Anne Mitchell. She's the nurse from the beginning of our story who ended up on trial. Anne had spent 30 years as a nurse, 20 of them at Winkler, working her way up. She'd held pretty much every nursing position, from floor nurse to director of nursing. When Arafiles arrived, she was the hospital's compliance officer. And it was her job to ensure the new doctors met the hospital's criteria. Arafiles didn't.
很多护士把对阿拉菲尔斯的担忧告诉了安妮·米切尔。她就是我们故事开头提到的那个最终被审判的护士。安妮做了30年护士，其中20年在温克勒医院，一步步升了上来。她几乎担任过所有的护理职位，从普通护士到护理部主任。当阿拉菲尔斯到来时，她是医院的合规官。确保新医生符合医院的标准是她的工作。阿拉菲尔斯不符合。
His license was restricted when he came. He could not supervise nurse practitioners.
他来的时候执照是受限的。他不能监管执业护士。
In 2007, the Texas Medical Board investigated Arafiles when he was working at a hospital in Victoria, Texas. Basically, it sounds like he was doing the same things there that the nurses would later see in Kermit. The TMB put Arafiles on probation. Anne says, according to Winkler Memorial's bylaws, they never should have hired him.
2007年，当阿拉菲尔斯在德克萨斯州维多利亚的一家医院工作时，德克萨斯州医学委员会调查了他。基本上，听起来他在那里做的事情和护士们后来在克米特看到的一模一样。医学委员会让阿拉菲尔斯处于缓刑期。安妮说，根据温克勒纪念医院的章程，他们根本就不应该雇佣他。
When I checked with the National Practitioner Data Bank, when he was first hired, that information came back. I took it to the board of control, because I wanted them to understand we were violating the medical staff bylaws and he was in violation of the contract that they signed to have him there.
当我第一次核查国家从业者数据银行时，他被雇佣时，该信息反馈了回来。我把它带到了控制委员会，因为我想让他们明白我们违反了医疗人员章程，而且他违反了他们签署的聘用合同。
Why was he hired with a restricted license anyway?
既然执照受限，他当初是怎么被雇佣的？
I can't answer that. I can only speculate that-- I will tell you this. In far west Texas, we don't have an abundance of people trying to get out here. That's why we had J-1 Visa doctors. And you have to wonder why a man in his 50's is not established somewhere. You have to question why somebody at that age, at that time in their life, would want to come to a small town like Kermit, Texas.
我无法回答。我只能推测——我会告诉你这个。在德克萨斯州的最西部，我们没有那么多想来这里的人。这就是为什么我们有J-1签证医生。你不得不怀疑为什么一个50多岁的人不在别处建立事业。你必须质疑为什么一个处于那个年龄、那个生命阶段的人，会想来克米特这样的小镇。
The person who hired Dr. Arafiles at Winkler Memorial was also a newcomer. Stan Wiley was the hospital's new administrator. He'd worked in hospital administration before, but when he was hired at Winkler, he was selling mobile homes. And he came in promising the hospital's board that he would bring in more money. Nurses say that under him, unnecessary tests were run, and admission standards were relaxed. When nurses took their complaints about Arafiles to Wiley, they say he seemed unconcerned. Here's Anne and Naomi.
在温克勒纪念医院雇佣阿拉菲尔斯医生的人也是个新人。斯坦·威利（Stan Wiley）是医院的新任行政长官。他以前从事过医院管理工作，但当他在温克勒被雇佣时，他正在卖活动房屋。他向医院董事会承诺他会带来更多的资金。护士们说，在他的管理下，进行了不必要的检查，准入标准也被放宽了。当护士们向威利提出关于阿拉菲尔斯的投诉时，她们说他似乎并不关心。这是安妮和娜奥米。
We were consistently bringing problems to Mr. Wiley.
我们一直在向威利先生反映问题。
The thing about Mr. Wiley is, you could tell him something. And he'd look you right in the eye and he'd say, good point, good point. But he never committed to fixing it.
关于威利先生的事情是，你可以告诉他某件事。他会直视你的眼睛说：“好的，好的。”但他从不承诺解决它。
Every time we discussed it, he bought a house here. That was the response I got. He bought a house here.
每次我们讨论这件事时，他就会说他在这里买了房。这就是我得到的回答。他在这里买了房。
This is Vickilyn Galle, another nurse whose job it was to review care.
这是维基琳·加勒（Vickilyn Galle），另一位负责审查护理工作的护士。
My issue was not where he had real estate. My issue was patient care. And that really didn't seem to be, in my opinion, a high priority for them.
我的问题不在于他在哪里有房地产。我的问题是病人的护理。在我看来，那似乎并不是他们的优先事项。
So you would come with your patient care concerns and Wiley would say, he bought a house?
所以你会带着病人护理的问题去找他，而威利会说，他在那里买了房子？
Yes. I had that response several times.
是的。我有几次得到过这样的回答。
Now, all this stuff, not looking at charts, prescribing herbal medicines. They were egregious. But not as shocking as what came next. Anne and Vicki started getting reports that Arafiles was performing surgeries, and that was odd for two reasons. One, Winkler Memorial didn't do surgeries. They hadn't had a surgeon on staff in decades, and any non-emergency surgeries were supposed to be sent to the hospital in Odessa, 40 miles away. The other problem, Dr. Arafiles wasn't a surgeon. He was a family practice doctor.
现在，所有这些事，不看病历、开草药。这些都很过分。但没有接下来发生的事情令人震惊。安妮和维基开始收到报告说阿拉菲尔斯在进行手术，这有两点很奇怪。第一，温克勒纪念医院不做手术。他们几十年来都没有外科医生，任何非紧急手术都应该送到40英里外的敖德萨（Odessa）的医院。另一个问题是，阿拉菲尔斯医生不是外科医生。他是家庭医学医生。
One surgery he performed was on a 73-year-old diabetic who came in with a gash on his hand. Arafiles cut a strip out of the man's abdomen, and performed a skin graft himself, right there in the emergency room. Debby Eggers was at the clinic when the man came in for a follow-up.
他做的一台手术是给一名73岁的糖尿病患者，患者手上有个伤口。阿拉菲尔斯从那个人的腹部切下一块皮，就在急诊室亲自做了植皮手术。当那个人回来复诊时，黛比·埃格斯在诊所。
When I first saw it, the hand looked good, good blood supply, didn't look like it was infected. The next time I saw it, it was black, hard like charcoal, and I couldn't see any blood supply or anything. I just thought the site did not take.
我第一次看到时，手看起来不错，血供良好，看起来没有感染。下一次我再看它时，它是黑色的，像木炭一样硬，我看不出任何血供或任何东西。我只是认为移植部位没成功。
Did Arafiles ever follow up with this guy? Did he see that the guy's graft had turned black?
阿拉菲尔斯跟进过这个病人吗？他有没有看到那家伙的移植部位变黑了？
Yes. After we unwrap it and stuff, he goes in there and he assessed the site. The patient actually told me that Dr. Arafiles called this his masterpiece. He thought it was OK and it was taking and there was no problems.
是的。在我们拆开包裹之后，他走过去评估了那个部位。病人实际上告诉我，阿拉菲尔斯医生称这为他的“杰作”。他认为它很好，正在生长，没有问题。
I just want to make sure I've got this right. This guy has a giant black patch on the back of his hand, and Arafiles looks at it, and what does he say?
我只是想确认我没听错。这家伙手背上有一大块黑斑，阿拉菲尔斯看了看，他说了什么？
That it looked good and come back in two weeks.
说看起来不错，两周后再来。
Debbie told Naomi Warren and the hospital's chief of staff what she'd seen. They referred the patient to a hand surgeon in Odessa. Another patient came in with a compound fracture on his thumb. Arafiles wanted to protect the thumb after he stabilized it, so he cut off a piece of rubber from the packaging of a suture kit and he sewed it on to the patient's thumb.
黛比把她看到的情况告诉了娜奥米·沃伦和医院的首席医疗官。他们把病人转诊到了敖德萨的一位手外科医生那里。另一个病人带着拇指复合骨折进来。阿拉菲尔斯在固定住拇指后想保护它，所以他从缝合包的包装上切下一块橡胶，缝在了病人的拇指上。
Now, normally it isn't nurses or even hospital administrators who are supposed to oversee doctors. It's other doctors. Since Winkler County only had two or three doctors at a time, their performance was reviewed by outside, statewide medical boards. One of these boards was a peer review service for rural hospitals provided by Texas A&M University.
现在，通常情况下，监督医生的不应该是护士甚至医院行政人员，而是其他医生。由于温克勒县一次只有两三名医生，他们的表现由外部的州级医疗委员会进行审查。这些委员会之一是德克萨斯农工大学为农村医院提供的同行评审服务。
Part of Vicki Galle's job was to send records to this peer review system. Sometimes they were files that were flagged for questionable care. Sometimes they were just random files. It was standard practice for rural hospitals across the state, and the way it had worked at Winkler for years. Until one day, when Stan Wiley, the hospital administrator, called Vicki into his office.
维基琳·加勒的工作一部分是发送记录到这个同行评审系统。有时是标记为护理可疑的文件。有时只是随机的文件。这对全州的农村医院来说是标准做法，也是温克勒多年来的工作方式。直到有一天，医院行政长官斯坦·威利把维基叫进了他的办公室。
I came in and sat down. I don't know if I was in his office over a minute. He was sitting there doing numbers, as he usually is. And he would use a ruler because he had lost one eye. And he looked up at me and said, don't send out any more records. I'll let you know when you can resume. And that was it. He said, that's it, you can go.
我走进去坐下。我不知道我在他办公室里有没有超过一分钟。他坐在那里算账，像往常一样。他会用尺子，因为他失去了一只眼睛。他抬头看着我说：“不要再发出任何记录了。我会在你可以恢复时通知你。”就这样。他说：“行了，你可以走了。”
What was your reaction?
你的反应是什么？
I was very upset. I went back to my office, talked to Anne about it when she came. And it just seemed to me to further show that they were trying to keep everything in house. In my opinion, we were going to deliver substandard care and just cover it up.
我非常难过。我回到办公室，当安妮进来时跟她说了这件事。在我看来，这进一步表明他们试图把一切内部消化。在我看来，我们是要提供不合格的护理并掩盖它。
Anne, Vicki, and Naomi had become the main stopgap against what they saw as Arafiles' substandard care. All of them kept trying to bring up their concerns at medical staff meetings and board meetings, but they were ignored. Meetings scheduled to discuss Arafiles' care kept getting cancelled. This is when some nurses at the hospital decided they'd had enough.
安妮、维基和娜奥米成为了抵制阿拉菲尔斯所谓不合格护理的主要防线。她们都一直试图在医疗人员会议和董事会会议上提出她们的担忧，但被忽视了。原定讨论阿拉菲尔斯护理问题的会议不断被取消。这时，一些医院的护士决定受够了。
In February 2009, Naomi Warren quit. At her final board meeting, Naomi tried to give a speech to explain why she was leaving. She said that it was a doctor's responsibility to submit his care to outside review, that if the board wanted a quality hospital, they must insist on quality patient care. That otherwise, Kermit's shiny new hospital would be a useless building.
2009年2月，娜奥米·沃伦辞职了。在她最后一次董事会会议上，娜奥米试图发表演讲解释她为什么要离开。她说，医生有责任将其护理情况提交外部审查，如果董事会想要一家优质的医院，他们必须坚持高质量的病人护理。否则，克米特崭新的医院将是一座无用的建筑。
During my talk, the board chairman was walking around the room, adjusting lights, causing such a distraction. That I thought I was going to-- I asked him once if I should start over. It was clear to me he wasn't interested in what I had to say. And he really didn't want anybody else to hear it either, I guess.
在我的谈话过程中，董事会主席在房间里走来走去，调节灯光，造成了很大的干扰。我以为我要……我问了他一次我是不是该重新开始。很明显，他对我要说的话不感兴趣。我想他也不想让别人听到。
The chief of staff and at least two other nurses left the hospital around the same time. With Naomi gone, Anne and Vicki felt they had only one option, reporting Dr. Arafiles to the Texas Medical Board. It was a big deal, sort of the last straw. Anne says she and Naomi and Vicki had long conversations about what to do.
首席医疗官和至少其他两名护士在同一时间离开了医院。娜奥米走后，安妮和维基觉得她们只有一个选择，即向德克萨斯州医学委员会报告阿拉菲尔斯医生。这是一件大事，算是压死骆驼的最后一根稻草。安妮说她和娜奥米、维基进行了长谈，讨论该怎么办。
Finally, I told her, I said, we have to do something because I don't know what else is going on that we don't know about.
最后，我告诉她，我说：“我们必须做点什么，因为我不知道还有什么我们不知道的事情正在发生。”
Anne and Vicki sat down and wrote their letter together. Anne was at the keyboard, typing it on her computer. Naomi wrote a letter also. She signed hers. Anne and Vicki left theirs anonymous. They put both letters together in one envelope. Anne told Naomi she'd mail the package from Odessa. She didn't want to take the risk of mailing it from Kermit. Here's Anne.
安妮和维基坐下来一起写了这封信。安妮坐在键盘前，在她的电脑上打字。娜奥米也写了一封信。她签署了自己的名字。安妮和维基把她们的信保持匿名。她们把两封信放在一个信封里。安妮告诉娜奥米她会从敖德萨寄出这个包裹。她不想冒从克米特寄出的风险。这是安妮的话。
I knew that if Mr. Wiley found out that we had sent that letter in that he would do everything he could to fire us from our positions.
我知道如果威利先生发现我们寄出了那封信，他会尽其所能把我们从岗位上解雇。
And I said, Anne, don't be ridiculous, they can't find out. This is confidential. It's protected. They're never going to find out that we did it. And I was a little bit put out with her, because I thought, why are you being so cautious? Why are you being so upset? When, in fact, I should have realized, I'm leaving. I don't have to face the scrutiny of Winkler County and the officials there. She had a much better pulse on the type of people we were dealing with.
我说：“安妮，别荒谬了，他们发现不了。这是保密的。它是受保护的。他们永远不会发现是我们做的。”我当时对她有点不高兴，因为我想，你为什么要这么谨慎？为什么要这么难过？事实上，我应该意识到，我要离开了。我不必面对温克勒县及那里官员的审查。她对我们要面对的人群有更好的判断。
Coming up, how a confidential letter ends up in the hands of exactly the people that it is supposed to be kept confidential from, and what kinds of things can happen as a result of that. Saul Elbein's story continues, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来说，一封保密信件是如何落入那些本应被保密的人手中，以及这会导致什么样的事情。索尔·埃尔拜因的故事将继续，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际，我们的节目稍后继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. If you're just tuning in, our show today is about old boys' networks. And we're in the middle of Act One, a story about some nurses who sent a letter off to the Texas Medical Board about what they saw as one doctor's questionable practices, and then they found themselves tangling with all kinds of powerful people in their town. When we left off, Anne Mitchell and two other nurses had just sent off their letters to the TMB. Here's reporter Saul Elbein.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。如果你刚加入，我们今天的节目是关于“老男孩网络”的。我们正在第一幕中，这是一个关于几名护士的故事，她们向德克萨斯州医学委员会发送了一封关于她们所见的一位医生可疑行为的信，然后发现自己与镇上各种有权势的人缠斗在一起。当我们离开时，安妮·米切尔和其他两名护士刚寄出了她们的信。这是记者索尔·埃尔拜因。
Six weeks later, Anne Mitchell started to hear strange rumors that the Winkler County sheriff, Robert Roberts, was doing an investigation. Word was that he was trying to find out who had complained about Dr. Arafiles.
六周后，安妮·米切尔开始听到奇怪的谣言，称温克勒县警长罗伯特·罗伯茨（Robert Roberts）正在进行调查。有传言说他正在试图找出是谁投诉了阿拉菲尔斯医生。
There was one person in the hospital that notified a friend of mine, who called me and said, Roberts is going to arrest somebody over this. Do you know who did it? Well, of course, I'm not going to say anything. I said, are you kidding me? No, Anne, he's looking to arrest somebody. I said, I can't believe that.
医院里有一个人通知了我的一个朋友，那个朋友打电话告诉我，罗伯茨要因为这件事逮捕某人。你知道是谁做的吗？嗯，当然，我什么都不会说。我说：“你在开玩笑吗？不，安妮，他在找人逮捕。”我说：“我不敢相信。”
Then I had another person who works in the hospital, she called me and she said that, if someone wasn't arrested for this, that Dr. Arafiles and Mr. Beckham were going to be very upset.
然后又有另一个在医院工作的人打电话给我，她说如果不是因为这件事有人被捕，阿拉菲尔斯医生和贝克姆（Beckham）先生会非常生气的。
Bill Beckham was the hospital's board president.
比尔·贝克姆是医院的董事会主席。
I knew that I had the right to do that. I had the right to question poor care. I had the right to report anything that I thought was inappropriate. And I really felt that we had nursing laws in place that protected me. And then I began to hear that, no, he's going to arrest whoever sent that letter in for harassment.
我知道我有权利这样做。我有质疑糟糕护理的权利。我有权利报告任何我认为不当的事情。我真的觉得我们有保护我的护理法律。然后我开始听说，不，他要以骚扰罪逮捕任何寄出那封信的人。
And I thought, OK, what do I do now? We need to find someone just in case. Just in case this happens. And so I called John Cook.
我想，好吧，现在我该怎么办？我们需要找个人以防万一。以防这种情况发生。所以我给约翰·库克打了电话。
And when she called, I think the first thing she said is, I'm not crazy.
当她打电话时，我想她说的第一件事是：“我不疯。”
This is John Cook, Anne Mitchell's attorney during the trial. Both he and Anne say that the initial conversation was a little awkward.
这是约翰·库克，安妮·米切尔审判期间的律师。他和安妮都说，最初的对话有点尴尬。
Our conversation consisted largely of, Anne, tell me what you did wrong. I would reiterate everything and he would say, yes, but tell me what you did wrong.
我们的对话主要包括：“安妮，告诉我你做错了什么。”我会重申一切，他会说：“是的，但告诉我你做错了什么。”
Quite honestly, I didn't believe what she was telling me. So I asked her if I could call her back, and I called a judge out in Kermit by the name of Bonnie Leck, who was the county court judge. And I said, hey, Bonnie, this lady called me. And immediately she said, she's not crazy, John. And I said, really? Are they that stupid? And her response was, they are going to do something.
老实说，我不相信她告诉我的一切。所以我问她我能否回电，我给克米特的一位叫邦妮·莱克（Bonnie Leck）的法官打了电话，她是县法院法官。我说：“嘿，邦妮，这位女士给我打了电话。”她立刻说：“她不疯，约翰。”我说：“真的？他们有那么蠢吗？”她的回应是：“他们要采取行动了。”
I was sure in my mind that once Sheriff Roberts started investigating and looked at what a nurse could and could not do and what was appropriate, that he would realize there's nothing in this letter that was inappropriate. There was nothing in there that said he's a rotten guy, I don't like him. There was nothing personal at all. It was all about how he practiced medicine.
我心里很清楚，一旦罗伯茨警长开始调查，并查看护士能做什么不能做什么以及什么是适当的，他就会意识到这封信里没有任何不当之处。里面没有任何东西说他是个坏蛋，我不喜欢他。里面完全没有个人色彩。一切都是关于他如何行医的。
Winkler County sheriff, Robert Roberts, is a big man with a big voice. He's pretty much what comes to mind when you hear the words, "West Texas Sheriff." And if you're wondering, like Anne was, why the county sheriff would launch a criminal investigation into a formal complaint to a medical board, there's this to consider. Roberts was good friends with Arafiles. The sheriff and the doctor played golf together. Roberts and his wife sold the herbal supplement, Zrii, for the Doctor. And Roberts says that Arafiles had saved his life when he had a heart attack in 2008..
温克勒县警长罗伯特·罗伯茨是个身材高大、嗓门洪亮的人。当你听到“西德克萨斯警长”这个词时，你脑海里想到的就是他。如果你像安妮一样纳闷，为什么县警长会对向医学委员会提出的正式投诉展开刑事调查，这里有件事需要考虑：罗伯茨和阿拉菲尔斯是好朋友。警长和医生一起打高尔夫球。罗伯茨和他的妻子为医生销售草药补充剂Zrii。罗伯茨说，他在2008年心脏病发作时，是阿拉菲尔斯救了他的命。
So when the Texas Medical Board sent Arafiles a letter telling him they had received a complaint about him and he was under investigation, he went to Sheriff Roberts and said he was being harassed. Roberts turned around and started his own investigation. But Roberts was missing his main piece of evidence, the actual letter the nurses had sent to the TMB. All he had was the notice that the TMB sent to Arafiles, saying they were looking into certain patient case numbers.
所以当德克萨斯州医学委员会给阿拉菲尔斯发信，告诉他他们收到了关于他的投诉，并且他正在接受调查时，他去了罗伯茨警长那里，说他受到了骚扰。罗伯茨转过身开始了自己的调查。但罗伯茨缺少他的主要证据——护士寄给医学委员会的实际信件。他手里只有医学委员会发给阿拉菲尔斯的通知，说他们正在调查某些病人的病例编号。
So Roberts took these case numbers and interviewed the corresponding patients. Taking this step was illegal. It was a breach of patient confidentiality. Because of pending criminal cases, Dr. Arafiles, Sheriff Roberts, Stan Wiley, and others are under a gag order and couldn't comment for this story.
所以罗伯茨拿着这些病例编号并采访了相应的病人。采取这一步骤是非法的。这是对病人保密的破坏。由于刑事案件正在审理中，阿拉菲尔斯医生、罗伯茨警长、斯坦·威利和其他人受到禁言令的约束，无法对这个故事发表评论。
It's unclear how Roberts got the patients' contact information in the first place. In any event, none of the patients said they'd filed a complaint. So Roberts knew it must have come from inside Winkler Memorial. So next, he got a list of 21 people who would have had access to the patient records. Both Vickilyn and Anne were on there.
目前还不清楚罗伯茨最初是如何获得病人联系信息的。无论如何，没有病人说他们提出了投诉。所以罗伯茨知道它一定来自温克勒纪念医院内部。于是接下来，他拿到了一份可能有权访问病人记录的21人名单。维基琳和安妮都在上面。
What happened then was the Sheriff came to the hospital and interviewed both of us, Vickilyn and I.
接下来发生的事情是，警长来到医院并采访了我们俩，维基琳和我。
And he had the bylaws in my face, saying you can't do any outside reporting. I told him, a nurse can't be arrested for reporting their concerns to the Texas Medical Board. Obviously, he didn't believe me when I said that.
他把章程摆在我面前，说你不能进行任何外部报告。我告诉他，护士不能因为向德克萨斯州医学委员会报告她们的担忧而被捕。显然，当我说这话时他不相信我。
And he kept asking me about policies and procedures and how my job worked and different things. And then he asked me, he said, now, Annie, I'm going to read this to you, and I don't want you to be scared. And I said, OK. And he Mirandized me. And I just looked at him, I said, OK. He said, now, I'm going to ask you a question. And I said, I'm not answering any of your questions, Robert. I'm working out here in a hostile environment. I'm going to call my attorney. And I left.
他不断地问我有关政策、程序、我的工作是如何运作的以及各种不同的事情。然后他问我，他说：“现在，安妮，我要给你念这个，我不想让你感到害怕。”我说：“好的。”他对我宣读了米兰达警告。我只是看着他，我说：“好的。他说，现在，我要问你一个问题。”我说：“我不会回答你的任何问题，罗伯特。我是在一个充满敌意的环境中工作。我要打电话给我的律师。”然后我离开了。
At this point, Roberts still hadn't seen the letter he was investigating. So he had to get a copy. Roberts wrote a letter asking the TMB for the complaint against Arafiles, and they sent it to him.
此时，罗伯茨还没看过他正在调查的那封信。所以他必须弄到一份副本。罗伯茨写了一封信要求医学委员会提供针对阿拉菲尔斯的投诉，他们寄给了他。
By law, the board is required to turn over information. It's just that simple.
根据法律，委员会被要求移交信息。就是这么简单。
This is Leigh Hopper. She's a spokesperson for the Texas Medical Board. The sheriff contacted the medical board and asked us for information relating to the investigation of Dr. Arafiles. And I think there was a cover letter that said that the identity of the complainants has to be treated as confidential, and it's protected by law and only used in connection with the criminal investigation of the doctor. And that it is not to be used for anything else.
这是利·霍珀（Leigh Hopper）。她是德克萨斯州医学委员会的发言人。“警长联系了医学委员会，并向我们索取与调查阿拉菲尔斯医生有关的信息。我想有一封公函，上面说投诉人的身份必须被视为机密，受法律保护，只能用于与医生的刑事调查有关的用途。它不能用于任何其他用途。”
You guys sent the letter with the assumption that it was being used in an investigation of Arafiles?
你们在假设它被用于调查阿拉菲尔斯的情况下寄出了信？
Right, because anything else would have been illegal.
是的，因为任何其他做法都是非法的。
So Roberts has Anne and Vicki's letter. Now, remember, Anne and Vicki's letter was anonymous, but they didn't work too hard to conceal their identities. In explaining why the letter is anonymous, the last paragraph of the letter states that, quote, "Due to the economic climate, the fact that I am over 50, female, and have been employed by this facility since the 1980s, I am hesitant to place a signature on this information."
所以罗伯茨拿到了安妮和维基的信。现在，记住，安妮和维基的信是匿名的，但她们并没有很努力地隐瞒自己的身份。在解释为什么信是匿名的时，信的最后一段写道：“鉴于经济环境、我已过50岁、女性、且自80年代起受雇于该设施的事实，我对签署这份信息感到迟疑。”
There were only two employees who matched that description, Anne and Vickilyn. But Roberts still didn't have any solid evidence to connect them to the complaint. For that, he needed a search warrant. That, and the cooperation of another powerful man in Kermit, Scott Tidwell.
只有两名符合该描述的员工，安妮和维基琳。但罗伯茨仍然没有任何确凿的证据将她们与投诉联系起来。为此，他需要搜查令。那，以及克米特另一位有权势的人——斯科特·提德威尔（Scott Tidwell）的配合。
Scott Tidwell is the Winkler County attorney.
斯科特·提德威尔是温克勒县的检察官。
This is Beau Berman. He covered the story for local CBS affiliate, KOSA-TV, in Odessa.
这是博·伯曼（Beau Berman）。他为敖德萨的哥伦比亚广播公司本地分支机构KOSA-TV报道了这个故事。
Because the actual district attorney was ill, Scott Tidwell took over the prosecuting duties. And some may argue that there's a conflict of interest there, because he was also the personal attorney for Dr. Arafiles and Sheriff Robert Roberts.
因为地区检察官生病了，斯科特·提德威尔接管了起诉职责。有人可能会争辩说这里存在利益冲突，因为他也是阿拉菲尔斯医生和罗伯茨警长的私人律师。
Not only was Tidwell Arafiles' and Robert's attorney, he was also the hospital's attorney, which meant that he was often in board meetings when the nurses were bringing up their concerns about Arafiles. And he was in on the decisions to ignore Anne and Vicki's concerns. Beau Berman says that when all this came out in the courtroom, people lost it.
提德威尔不仅是阿拉菲尔斯和罗伯茨的律师，他还是医院的律师，这意味着当护士们向阿拉菲尔斯提出担忧时，他经常在董事会会议上。他参与了忽视安妮和维基担忧的决定。博·伯曼说，当这一切在法庭上曝光时，人们惊呆了。
There was just this chatter that overtook the courtroom, this almost laughter when people found that out. Because it just seemed so ridiculous that this county attorney had such a close relationship-- and actually had clients-- that were so closely involved to this case. It was like a farce, honestly. This whole deal was almost like a satire. At times, you couldn't believe this was happening.
法庭上爆发出一阵交谈声，当人们发现这一点时，几乎是笑声。因为这个县检察官与这个案件有着如此密切的关系——实际上还有客户——这看起来太荒谬了。这就像一场闹剧，老实说。整个事情几乎像是一部讽刺剧。有时候，你简直不敢相信这是真的。
And so, Scott Tidwell talks about how he golfs with the sheriff, how he's also the sheriff's personal attorney, but then denied that there was any sort of conflict of interest or that he was just prosecuting this case because he liked the sheriff. Or because he knew him. Or anything like that. And Scott Tidwell doesn't have the best name in Odessa. He was involved in a prior incident in Odessa. But you can research that on your own, probably.
所以，斯科特·提德威尔谈到他是如何与警长打高尔夫球，他是如何同时担任警长的私人律师的，但随后否认存在任何利益冲突，或者他起诉这个案子只是因为他喜欢警长。或者因为他认识他。或者类似的任何事情。斯科特·提德威尔在敖德萨的名声并不好。他参与了敖德萨之前的一起事件。但你可以自己去研究一下。
I did research it. What Beau is referring to is something that takes this case to a whole new level of seediness. In 2004, Scott Tidwell had been charged in a scandal involving a massage parlor called The Healing Touch. The Healing Touch was the subject of a year-long prostitution investigation that resulted in 61 arrests. According to press accounts, Tidwell was a client, and he threw parties with prostitutes for some of his firm's clients.
我确实研究了。博所指的事情让这个案件进入了一个全新的低级程度。2004年，斯科特·提德威尔卷入了一起涉及一家名为“治愈之触”（The Healing Touch）的按摩院的丑闻。那是一家开展了长达一年的卖淫调查的机构，导致了61人被捕。据媒体报道，提德威尔是客户，他为他公司的一些客户举办了带有妓女的派对。
He was charged with prostitution and promoting prostitution. He pled guilty to the prostitution charge, and the other charges were dismissed. Tidwell left Odessa shortly after and moved to Kermit, where he ran for county attorney. Sheriff Roberts campaigned for him.
他被控卖淫和引诱卖淫。他承认了卖淫指控，其他指控被驳回。提德威尔不久后离开了敖德萨，搬到了克米特，在那里竞选县检察官。罗伯茨警长为他竞选。
In any case, with Tidwell's help, Sheriff Roberts got a warrant to seize Anne and Vicki's computers. Anne had a part-time gig in Kermit's Homeland Security office, and there, in the My Documents folder of Anne's Homeland Security computer, Roberts found what he was looking for. Anne and Vickilyn's letter to the TMB. Two weeks later, Stan Wiley fired Anne and Vicki. 10 days after that, they were both indicted.
无论如何，在提德威尔的帮助下，罗伯茨警长获得了查封安妮和维基电脑的搜查令。安妮在克米特的国土安全办公室有一份兼职工作，在那里，在安妮的国土安全电脑的“我的文档”文件夹中，罗伯茨找到了他要找的东西。安妮和维基琳给医学委员会的信。两周后，斯坦·威利解雇了安妮和维基。10天后，她们俩被起诉。
But looking at the facts of the case, it's pretty obvious that the only nurse they were after was Anne Mitchell. Roberts didn't know that Vicki had collaborated on the letter until she told him. And even though Naomi had signed her letter, he never investigated her. He never even talked to her about it. Everyone in town says that Naomi was so beloved that there was no way they'd go after her. But why Anne? I asked Naomi about it.
但看看案件的事实，很明显他们针对的唯一护士是安妮·米切尔。罗伯茨不知道维基参与了这封信，直到她告诉他。尽管娜奥米签署了她的信，但他从未调查过她。他甚至从未和她谈论过这件事。镇上的每个人都说娜奥米太受爱戴了，所以他们不可能针对她。但为什么是安妮？我问了娜奥米。
Anne, quite frankly, is a Yankee.
安妮，坦率地说，是个“北方佬”。
Anne had come from upstate New York, but she moved to Texas over 20 years ago. She married an oil roughneck. She speaks with more than a hint of a Texas accent. But Naomi says there was something about Anne that stood out.
安妮来自纽约州北部，但她20多年前搬到了德克萨斯州。她嫁给了一个石油钻井工人。她说话时带有一丝德克萨斯口音。但娜奥米说安妮身上有一些突出的东西。
When you come to an area like west Texas, there's a certain culture here. You don't roll in and say what you think, especially to a lot of men. So I think that she was unintentionally pushy, but that that's her way. She says what she thinks. She doesn't play the southern belle.
当你来到像西德克萨斯这样的地区，这里有一种特定的文化。你不会在那指手画脚说出你的想法，尤其是对很多男人。所以我认为她无意中很强势，但这只是她的方式。她说出她的想法。她不扮演南方淑女。
Which Vicki does?
维基会那样吗？
Yes, and I to a certain extent, because we're old southern gals. That's the way it is. So I don't think she went over really well with the good ol' boys.
是的，我也会在一定程度上，因为我们是老派的南方姑娘。就是这样。所以我认为她和那些“老男孩”相处得不太好。
From the beginning, it was clear that Scott Tidwell's case against Anne and Vicki was weak. The charge was misuse of official information. Essentially, the accusation was that the nurses harassed Arafiles simply by sending their letter to the Texas Medical Board. It was a felony charge. Anne and Vicki were facing a possible $10,000 fine and 10 years in prison. But in July, a month after they were indicted, Tidwell made their lawyer, John Cook, an offer.
从一开始就很清楚，斯科特·提德威尔针对安妮和维基的案子很弱。指控是滥用官方信息。本质上，指控是护士们仅仅通过向德克萨斯州医学委员会发送那封信就骚扰了阿拉菲尔斯。这是一项重罪指控。安妮和维基面临可能的1万美元罚款和10年监禁。但在7月，在她们被起诉一个月后，提德威尔向她们的律师约翰·库克提供了一个提议。
They wrote us a letter, and told us that if they would not contest their firing, if they would release Winkler County and the hospital from any type of civil liability, that they would dismiss the criminal case. And what that really is saying is, if you all would just go away, we'll leave you alone.
他们写信给我们，说如果她们不抗辩被解雇的事实，如果她们免除温克勒县和医院的任何类型的民事责任，他们就会撤销刑事案件。这实际上是在说，如果你们都走开，我们就别管你们。
Anne and Vicki didn't take the offer.
安妮和维基没有接受这个提议。
I believe that they got to the point where they thought the only way that they could get out of this thing was to convict Anne Mitchell. They saw that as a way that, yes, this is not going well. But if we get a conviction, it'll be OK.
我相信她们到了那种程度，认为她们摆脱这件事的唯一方法就是定安妮·米切尔的罪。她们把这看作是一种……是的，事情进展不顺利。但如果我们定罪，那就没问题了。
After jury selection, I had a private talk with Mr. Tidwell. And I told him, I said, Scotty, you need to dismiss this. You need to dismiss this now. You have no idea what is coming down the pike. And Scott's response was, well, I've taken it this far and I don't see anything else to do but just let the jury decide it.
在陪审团选拔后，我与提德威尔先生进行了一次私人谈话。我告诉他：“斯科蒂，你需要撤销这个案子。你现在需要撤销它。你根本不知道接下来会发生什么。”斯科特的回答是：“嗯，我已经走到这一步了，除了让陪审团决定，我看不到别的办法。”
At least, let the jury decide Anne's case. A week before the trial began, to everyone's surprise, the prosecution dropped all charges against Vickilyn Galle. They gave no reason. Anne's case, based on the exact same evidence, moved forward.
至少，让陪审团决定安妮的案子。在审判开始前一周，令所有人惊讶的是，检察官撤销了对维基琳·加勒的所有指控。他们没有给出任何理由。基于完全相同的证据，安妮的案子向前推进了。
I could pick a lot of things to demonstrate how ridiculous the trial was. There's this exchange about the skin graft that turned black. Anne's attorney had a sketch Arafiles had made. He asked Arafiles, and you cut off a portion of his abdomen, didn't you?
我可以挑选很多事情来展示审判是多么荒谬。关于那个变黑的植皮手术，有一段交流。安妮的律师有阿拉菲尔斯画的一张草图。他问阿拉菲尔斯：“你从他的腹部切下了一部分，不是吗？”
No, sir.
没有，长官。
Well, do you recognize that drawing, Doctor?
那么，你认得那幅画吗，医生？
Yes, sir.
是的，长官。
Who made that drawing?
那幅画是谁画的？
Me, sir.
我，长官。
What is the bottom part of that drawing supposed to represent?
那幅画的下半部分代表什么？
Skin, sir.
皮肤，长官。
And where did that skin come from, sir?
那块皮肤是从哪里来的，长官？
From his abdomen, sir.
从他的腹部，长官。
Did it fall off?
它掉下来了吗？
No, sir.
没有，长官。
Did you cut it off?
是你把它割下来的吗？
Yes, sir.
是的，长官。
At several times throughout the trial, the judge had to warn spectators to curb their laughter. TV reporter Beau Berman says he couldn't really believe what he was hearing.
在审判期间，法官多次不得不警告旁观者克制笑声。电视记者博·伯曼说他真的无法相信他所听到的一切。
In the early stages of this, my thought process was, wow, it appears as though these guys are going to get away with this. That was my personal feeling, when I take off my reporter hat. Even when I leave it on. But as it went on, I started to think, when it got to the trial, the more you started to think about it, you start to realize, how well did these conspirators, you might call them, really think this through? Because all of their evidence or all of their reasoning for doing everything they did is ultimately going to come out on the stand. And that's under oath. That's official, that's on the record. And there's a transcript of it.
在最初阶段，我的想法是，哇，看起来这些人要逃脱了。当我摘下记者的帽子时，这是我的个人感觉。甚至当我戴着它时也是如此。但随着审判的进行，当你开始考虑它时，你开始意识到，这些被你称为共谋者的人，真的仔细思考过吗？因为他们所做的一切的所有证据或所有推理最终都会在证人席上被揭露。而且那是在宣誓下。那是官方的，那是记录在案的。而且有文字记录。
And in fact, Arafiles admits, on the stand, to the questionable medical practices that Anne and Vicki wrote to the TMB about. Sheriff Roberts admits that he approached patients in his investigation, which the TMB says is illegal. He admits he used the nurse's complaint to the TMB to investigate them, which the TMB says is illegal. Prosecutor Tidwell admits that he's also the personal attorney of the sheriff and the doctor and the hospital. Again, TV reporter, Beau Berman.
事实上，阿拉菲尔斯在证人席上承认了安妮和维基写给医学委员会的那种可疑医疗行为。罗伯茨警长承认他在调查中接触了病人，医学委员会说这是非法的。他承认他利用护士向医学委员会的投诉来调查她们，医学委员会说这是非法的。检察官提德威尔承认他同时是警长、医生和医院的私人律师。再次引用电视记者博·伯曼的话。
There were times where I really wanted to just kind of say to my audience, can you even believe this is happening?
有那么几次我真的想对我的观众说：你们简直不敢相信这正在发生，对吗？
Reading the transcript, it's shocking just how open the men who tried to take down Anne and Vicki are about what they did. It's as if they never truly expected the case to go to trial, like they expected Anne and Vicki to give in and go away. Anne, of course, won the case, after either five minutes or one hour of jury deliberation, depending on how you count it.
读着文字记录，试图打倒安妮和维基的这些人竟然如此公开他们所做的事情，这太令人震惊了。就好像他们从未真正期望案件会进入审判阶段，就好像他们期望安妮和维基会屈服并走开。安妮当然赢得了这个案子，是在陪审团审议了五分钟还是一个小时之后，取决于你如何计算。
Of course I was relieved, naturally. I mean, who wouldn't be relieved after 10 months worrying about where you're going to be? And then it was like, OK, they still have this problem at the hospital.
我当然松了一口气，自然。我的意思是，在担心了10个月之后，谁不会松一口气呢？然后就像，好的，医院里还有问题。
Namely, that Arafiles was still a doctor there. In fact, he was still working at Winkler Memorial until April 15 of this year, more than a year after Anne's trial. He's still licensed by the State of Texas. I didn't understand how this was possible. And when I called Winkler Memorial, they suggested I talk to the new board president, Stefanie Haley.
也就是说，阿拉菲尔斯仍然是那里的医生。事实上，直到今年4月15日，即安妮审判一年多后，他还在温克勒纪念医院工作。他仍然拥有德克萨斯州的执照。我不明白这怎么可能。当我打电话给温克勒纪念医院时，他们建议我与新任董事会主席斯蒂芬妮·海莉（Stefanie Haley）谈谈。
I think the really obvious question here is, why wasn't Dr. A. fired after he was under investigation by the medical board for all this stuff, and after the trial?
我认为这里一个显而易见的问题是：为什么阿拉菲尔斯医生在因所有这些事情受到医学委员会调查并且审判之后，没有被解雇？
Well, now, there's 10,000 stories on that. And I think a lot of it is, we just had one big huge suit with the nurses. And I think that the county and the hospital really was afraid, maybe, just he would do a frivolous lawsuit. That Dr. A. would against the hospital. And already our image was terribly tarnished. And I think they decided just to-- I know we did the last few months-- just grit your teeth and let his contract end.
好吧，关于这个有10,000个故事。我认为很大一部分原因是我们刚和护士们打了一场大官司。我认为县政府和医院可能真的害怕，也许他会对医院提起诉讼。这会损害我们的形象。我想他们决定只是……我知道我们在过去几个月里所做的是……咬紧牙关，让他合同期满。
Weren't you guys worried that he was going to hurt someone in that time that you were waiting and gritting your teeth?
你们不担心他在等待和咬牙期间伤害到人吗？
That's one of the reasons why we took him off the ER. He couldn't do procedures. And then, finally, we even tried to keep him out of the ER unless we had to have him just for lack of doctors. But when he was in there, he had to have another doctor. If he gave a prescription, if he was going to perform anything, the other doctor had to approve of it. I know it's kind of complicated. It is a complicated thing, and something that we're glad we're over with.
这就是为什么我们将他调离急诊室的原因之一。他不能进行手术。然后，最后，我们甚至试图让他远离急诊室，除非我们因为医生短缺而不得不让他参与。但当他在那里时，必须有另一位医生。如果他开了处方，如果他要做任何事情，另一位医生必须批准它。我知道这有点复杂。这是一个复杂的事情，也是我们很高兴能结束的事情。
The Texas Medical Board finished its investigation of Arafiles in February. He's been fined $5,000 for retaliating against the nurses, and he has a year to answer their questions about his old cases if he's going to have restrictions removed from his medical license. Another doctor monitors everything he does, and he has to pay for that, which will cost him tens of thousands of dollars.
德克萨斯州医学委员会在2月完成了对阿拉菲尔斯的调查。他因报复护士被罚款5,000美元，如果他想撤销医疗执照上的限制，他有一年时间来回答关于他旧病例的问题。另一名医生监控他所做的一切，他必须为此付费，这将花费他数万美元。
As for Anne and Vicki, they say their nursing careers are over, that they'd have to start at the bottom again at a new hospital, leave their lives in west Texas, and they're not going to do that. They've become advocates for patients' rights, and they spend their time speaking to nursing associations in Texas and around the country. They filed a civil suit against Winkler County that settled for $750,000. Anne and Vicki had to split that, and that's before attorney's fees and taxes.
至于安妮和维基，她们说她们的护理生涯结束了，她们得在一家新医院从底层做起，离开她们在西德克萨斯的家，她们不会那样做。她们已成为病人权利的倡导者，她们把时间花在向德克萨斯州和全国各地的护理协会发表演讲上。她们对温克勒县提起了民事诉讼，以75万美元达成了和解。安妮和维基不得不平分这笔钱，这还没扣除律师费和税款。
In December, a special prosecutor from the Texas Attorney General's office indicted Arafiles for felony retaliation, and, in a karmic twist, misuse of official information, the same charge leveled at Anne and Vicki. Three weeks later, Sheriff Roberts, the county attorney, Scott Tidwell, and hospital administrator, Stan Wiley, were indicted, too, for misuse of official information, retaliation, and official oppression. On June 6, Sheriff Roberts will be the first to go to trial.
12月，德克萨斯州总检察长办公室的一名特别检察官以重罪报复罪起诉了阿拉菲尔斯，并且，在一个因果报应的转折中，以滥用官方信息罪起诉了他——这就是当初安妮和维基受到的指控。三周后，罗伯茨警长、县检察官斯科特·提德威尔和医院行政长官斯坦·威利也因滥用官方信息罪、报复罪和滥用职权罪被起诉。6月6日，罗伯茨警长将成为第一个受审的人。
Winkler Memorial still faces a lot of the same problems it did before. It's still a small hospital in a small town that not many people want to move to. The same is true in east Texas. Arafiles just took a job there at a hospital in a town called Grand Saline. It's even smaller than Kermit. He's one of three doctors on staff there. Grand Saline, like Kermit, needs doctors.
温克勒纪念医院仍然面临着许多和以前一样的问题。它仍然是一个小镇里的小医院，没多少人愿意搬过去。德克萨斯州东部也是如此。阿拉菲尔斯刚刚在那里的一家小镇医院找到了一份工作，叫大萨林（Grand Saline）。它比克米特还要小。他是那里在职的三名医生之一。大萨林和克米特一样，需要医生。
Saul Elbein is a reporter in Austin, Texas. He reported a version of this story for The Texas Observer.
索尔·埃尔拜因是德克萨斯州奥斯汀的一名记者。他为《德克萨斯观察家》（The Texas Observer）报道了这个故事的一个版本。
[MUSIC - "MEDICINE SHOW" BY BIG AUDIO DYNAMITE]
[音乐 - 大音频炸药乐队（Big Audio Dynamite）的《Medicine Show》]
Act Two, Donkey See, Donkey Do. Well, now we turn from people defying the old boys' network in their town to people bowing before it. The people in this case, lawyers who want to be judges in the city of Chicago. Chicago is going through some changes lately. They have a new mayor who's not named Richard Daley, which hasn't happened very often during the last 50 years.
第二幕：驴子看，驴子学。好吧，现在我们将目光从那些在小镇反抗“老男孩网络”的人转向那些向它低头的人。这些人是那些想成为芝加哥法官的律师。芝加哥最近正在经历一些变化。他们有一位新市长，名字不叫理查德·戴利（Richard Daley），这在过去50年里不经常发生。
But some things haven't changed. And every two years, much of the Chicago political machine-- that's the Democratic machine, the only one that actually counts in Chicago-- meets in a hotel across the street from City Hall. It's the 50 Ward committeemen, the 30 Township committeemen. These are the sergeants who boss around the foot soldiers of the Democratic machine. These are party officials.
但有些事情没变。每两年，芝加哥政治机器的大部分——那是民主党机器，在芝加哥唯一真正有影响力的机器——会在市政厅对面的酒店开会。那是50个区党部主任，30个乡镇部主任。这些是指挥民主党机器的士兵的士官。这些是党内官员。
And if you want to become a judge, you go before them and try to get your name put onto the official Democratic Party ticket on the ballot, which helps. Chicago's a city that elects its judges, and there are always so many judges up for election-- dozens of names on the ballot-- too many to know who they are. This is one area where lots of people will just vote for whoever the party recommends. So, candidates come up before the Democratic Party machine, in what used to be literally a smoke-filled room. When indoor smoking was allowed in Chicago.
如果你想成为法官，你就要去他们面前，试图把你的名字列入选票上的官方民主党候选人名单，这会有所帮助。芝加哥是一个选举法官的城市，总是有那么多的法官竞选——选票上有几十个名字——多到不知道他们是谁。这是一个很多选民只会投给党派推荐的人的领域。所以，候选人出现在民主党机器面前，在过去甚至是在烟雾缭绕的房间里。当芝加哥允许室内吸烟时。
This is largely a ceremonial pageant, because they've already made up their mind and cut their deal of who's going to get the blessing. But they go ahead with the show and let people get up and speak their piece.
这在很大程度上是一场仪式性的选秀，因为他们已经下定了决心并达成了谁将获得祝福的协议。但他们还是继续表演，让人们上去说出自己的见解。
That's Abdon Pallasch. The political reporter is probably the leading chronicler of this living remnant of the old Chicago machine. He's covered it since 1996, in recent years for the Chicago Sun-Times. He says it's not entirely a show. Often, there are decisions to make. They have to choose among several politically connected candidates for a few slots. And the main quality that they're looking for?
那是阿布顿·帕拉斯（Abdon Pallasch）。这位政治记者可能是这个芝加哥老机器存活遗迹的主要记录者。自1996年以来，他一直在报道这件事，近年来为《芝加哥太阳报》工作。他说这不完全是一场表演。通常会有决定要做。他们必须在几个有政治背景的候选人中为几个名额进行选择。他们寻找的主要品质是什么？
Loyalty. There's an old saying in both Daley administrations, old man, Richard J. Daley and the son, Richard M. Daley. What do you call 99% loyalty? Disloyalty.
忠诚。戴利政府（老理查德·J·戴利和儿子理查德·M·戴利）有一句老话。你怎么称呼99%的忠诚？不忠诚。
And so, when Abdon wrote about the 2003 meeting to choose which judges were going to go onto the Democratic ticket, he noted that nearly all of the 25 judge wannabes began their presentations with the same first sentence.
所以，当阿布顿写到2003年关于选择哪些法官进入民主党名单的会议时，他注意到几乎所有25名想当法官的人都以同样的第一个句子开始了他们的陈述。
I am a lifelong Democrat. Because that's what it's about. These aren't law school deans making this choice. These are Democratic Ward committeemen. It is their job to turn out the votes for the Democrats on Election Day.
“我是终身民主党人。”因为这就是这件事的意义所在。做出这种选择的不是法学院院长。这些是民主党区党部主任。他们的工作是在选举日为民主党争取选票。
One of the things in this 2003 account that I thought was really charming-- so they all stand up and say, I'm a lifelong Democrat. And then there's a candidate named Anna Helen Demacopoulos?
在2003年的这份报道中，我认为非常迷人的一件事是——他们都站起来说，我是终身民主党人。然后有一个叫安娜·海伦·德马科普洛斯（Anna Helen Demacopoulos）的候选人？
Yes.
是的。
Can I ask you to read your account of what happens when she stands up?
我能请你读一下她站起来时发生的事情的记述吗？
Anna Helen Demacopoulos tells committeemen she really means lifelong. Demacopoulos, when you translate that, literally, in ancient Greek, it means son of a Democrat. So I guess you can say, ladies and gentlemen, that I was born a Democrat, she says. It was a nice try, didn't work. She didn't get slated, didn't have enough political clout.
“安娜·海伦·德马科普洛斯告诉党部主任，她真的是指‘终身’。德马科普洛斯，翻译过来，在古希腊语中，字面意思是‘民主党人的儿子’。所以我猜你可以说，女士们先生们，我是天生的民主党人，”她说。这是一个很好的尝试，没用。她没有入选，没有足够的政治影响力。
So what's expected of them? And what mistakes have you seen people in that setting?
那么对他们的期望是什么？你在那种环境下看到人们犯过什么错误？
A lot of lawyers who want to become a judge and who haven't done their homework, they don't know this is how the game is played. And they think this is just like going before a bar group. They'll come in and they'll talk for 10 minutes about their resume, here I worked at this law firm, I worked at that law firm. Maybe they'll actually pass out 25-page resumes, and the committeemen will kind of roll their eyes. I graduated magna cum laude from my law school. I spent a summer abroad in Costa Rica.
很多想成为法官且没做功课的律师，他们不知道这个游戏是怎么玩的。他们认为这就像在律师团体面前展示。他们会进来花10分钟谈论他们的简历，我在这里的律师事务所工作过，我在那里的律师事务所工作过。也许他们会分发25页的简历，党部主任会翻白眼。“我以优异成绩从法学院毕业。我在哥斯达黎加度过了一个夏天。”
And the committeemen's eyes will glaze over, because that actually counts against you. Spending time outside Chicago. The best thing you'll say is, I never left Chicago. I went to grade school at St. Mary's and I've never left-- and I went to law school at DePaul. And I've been here. Every Monday night I go to my Ward office for my alderman and I give free legal advice to his constituents. That's what they want to hear.
党部主任的眼睛会失神，因为那实际上会扣分。在芝加哥以外的地方花时间。你能说的最好的话是，“我从未离开过芝加哥。我在圣玛丽小学上学，我从未离开过——我在德保罗大学上了法学院。我一直在这里。每个周一晚上我都去我的选区办公室找我的市议员，我为他的选民提供免费的法律咨询。”那就是他们想听到的。
And so, when they don't hear that, when a guy actually gives his credentials, what happens?
所以当他们没听到这些，当一个人真的展示了他的资历时，会发生什么？
They smile and say, thank you very much. Next. And you can pretty much spot the ones where it's been decided. This person's going to get the slating for the judgeship. Because they get up, they speak very briefly. They say, I've got good ratings from the bar groups. My alderman is Alderman Burke, and I would welcome your support. Thank you very much. And maybe one or two committeemen will get up and speak on their behalf, and they'll say, thank you very much. Next.
他们会微笑说：“非常感谢。下一个。”你可以大致判断出谁被决定了。这个人会获得法官提名。因为他们站起来，说得非常简短。他们说，“我有律师团的好评。我的市议员是伯克（Burke），我会欢迎你们的支持。非常感谢。”也许一两个党部主任会站起来为他们说话，然后他们会说：“非常感谢。下一个。”
You describe a wannabe candidate, Denise Staniec, who's the former head of the Women's Bar in Illinois, get up before the committeemen. And usually if you're going to be successful, somebody's going to stand up and speak for you. Can I just ask you to read from your account of what happens to her?
你描述了一位候选人，丹妮丝·斯坦尼克（Denise Staniec），她是伊利诺伊州妇女律师协会的前负责人，在党部主任面前站起来。通常如果你想成功，有人会站出来为你说话。我能请你读一下关于她发生的事情的记述吗？
Sure. None of the committeemen stand to speak on her behalf, not even those she calls to by name. Some are still shaking their heads over her impertinence a few weeks ago at a slating session held for the 8th Judicial Subcircuit. That meeting was chaired by retiring 42nd Ward Committeeman, George Dunne, who appeared to nod off during her talk, until Staniec stopped midspeech, grabbed the 90-year-old Dunne by the arm, shook him awake and shouted, Mr. Dunne, please don't leave me now.
当然。“没有一个党部主任站出来为她说话，即使是那些她点名的人。一些人还在对她几周前在第8司法分区选秀会议上的冒失行为摇头。那次会议由即将退休的第42区党部主任乔治·邓恩（George Dunne）主持，他在她说话时似乎打瞌睡了，直到斯坦尼克中途停下来，抓住90岁的邓恩的胳膊，把他摇醒并大喊：‘邓恩先生，请现在别离开我。’”
Now, when you're there in one of these meetings, you see a lawyer named James C. Murray stand up. And you write, quote, "Burke all but says that a seat on the bench has been saved for Murray for 40 years." Can I ask you to just tell the story of why?
现在，当你参加这些会议之一时，你会看到一个名叫詹姆斯·C·默里（James C. Murray）的律师站起来。你写道，引述，“伯克几乎说法官席已经为默里留了40年。”我能请你讲讲原因吗？
So, Ed Burke, the alderman who runs the judicial slating session, just looking at his face is often a good gauge of who's going to be slated. And Burke, as Murray gets up there, Burke says, if there's ever a book entitled Chicago Profiles in Courage, this man's father would go on the top of that list. James Murray, the elder, was an alderman under Richard J. Daley. And when Richard J. Daley needed someone to sponsor the Open Housing Ordinance back in the '60s, he picked Murray. And Murray knew this was going to be his political death sentence.
所以，运行司法选秀会议的市议员埃德·伯克（Ed Burke），观察他的脸通常是判断谁会入选的一个好方法。当默里走上去时，伯克说：“如果有一本书叫《芝加哥勇气侧写》，这个人的父亲会排在名单的首位。”老詹姆斯·默里是理查德·J·戴利手下的市议员。当戴利需要有人在60年代发起开放住房条例时，他选中了默里。而默里知道这将是他的政治死刑判决。
And this ordinance, was it a pro-civil rights or an anti-civil rights ordinance?
这个条例，它是支持民权的还是反对民权的？
Oh, this is pro. This was an integration. This was stopping realtors from being able to play games to keep people out of certain neighborhoods.
噢，这是支持的。这是关于融合。这是为了阻止房地产商玩把戏把人排斥在特定社区之外。
And he was basically in a ward where the white population wouldn't want that?
他基本上在白人选民不想看到这一点的选区？
Yes. But he sponsored the ordinance anyway, and it passed, and he was voted out of office. And so, 40 years later, Burke's line is, this seat's been reserved for Murray for 40 years.
是的。但他还是发起该条例，它通过了，他被投票赶下了台。所以40年后，伯克的台词是，这个席位已经为默里留了40年。
You know, what's surprising isn't that this happens, that committeemen are choosing judges based on connections and politics, but that everyone is so open about it. You know what I mean? Like, there's no code of silence. There's no secret language. There's no pretending that something else is happening.
你知道，令人惊讶的不是这种情况发生了，即党部主任基于人脉和政治选择法官，而是每个人都对此如此公开。你明白我的意思吗？就像，没有沉默法典。没有秘密语言。没有假装在发生其他事情。
And when you bring up the argument some of the bar groups bring up about, shouldn't we have merit selection, appointed judges? They say, well, look at the states that have that. It's the governors that appoint judges. Would Governor Blagojevich or Governor Ryan appoint better judges than the ones we're picking?
当你提出一些律师团体提出的关于“我们不是应该有择优选择，任命法官吗？”的论点时，他们说，“嗯，看看那些有这些制度的州吧。是州长任命法官。布拉戈耶维奇（Blagojevich）州长或瑞安（Ryan）州长会比我们选的人选得更好吗？”
I should say, Blagojevich, of course, is currently on trial for selling a Senate seat. Ryan is serving six and a half years on corruption charges.
我应该说，布拉戈耶维奇目前正因出售参议院席位而受审。瑞安正因腐败指控服刑六年半。
Yes. And there's the appointive systems. If it's law groups, are they going to pick corporate lawyers who live in the wealthy suburbs and can't sympathize with the rights of the common man? We want judges who will sit on the bench and when they see a working guy come in there, be able to identify them and be fair to them. So that's the committeemen arguing for keeping the current status quo system of the committeemen helping pick judges. But the voters make the ultimate choice.
是的。任命制也是如此。如果是法律团体，他们会选那些住在富裕郊区、无法同情普通人权利的企业律师吗？我们想要那些坐在法官席上，当看到普通劳动者进来时，能够认同他们并对他们公平的法官。所以那是党部主任们支持保留党部主任参与挑选法官的现状体系的论点。但选民做出最终选择。
Yeah, but it isn't that these guys are showing such loyalty to the working man. These guys are showing loyalty to Democratic Party machinery, which is them.
是的，但并不是这些人对劳动者表现出如此忠诚。这些人对民主党机制表现出忠诚，那就是他们自己。
That's exactly right. But part of the problem is now there's national business groups that have targeted Illinois, and Cook County, in specific, as a terrible place to try cases. Because, they say, the Democratic Party so dominates the choosing of judges here that verdicts are lopsided against businesses. And they've had some numbers to back that up.
那完全正确。但问题的一部分是现在有全国商业团体将伊利诺伊州，特别是库克县，作为尝试诉讼的糟糕场所。因为他们说，民主党在这里支配法官的选择，以至于判决结果对企业不平衡。他们有一些数据支持这一点。
Over his years covering this, Abdon has seen a change. Various constituency groups-- minorities, women-- have demanded judgeships. And they have gotten slated by the Democratic Party. Abdon says that the committeemen point to the diversity on the Chicago bench as one of the advantages of slating judges this way. And since Abdon started writing about the meeting, and committeemen started seeing how it came off in the newspaper, they have made some adjustments.
在他报道这件事的这些年里，阿布顿看到了变化。各种选民团体——少数族裔、女性——要求获得法官职位。他们被民主党提名了。阿布顿说党部主任指出芝加哥法官席上的多样性是这样提名法官的好处之一。自从阿布顿开始写关于会议的文章，党部主任开始看到它在报纸上是如何表现出来的，他们做了一些调整。
I've watched it progress from fairly raw politicking to a little more polished and trying to give the appearance of, we really care about these candidates' credentials. And we want lawyers who actually have good ratings from the bar associations and will actually perform well on the bench. They're more conscious of how this looks in the public arena. And so, they just know to be a little bit more discreet in talking about how loyal a party member, how many doorbells this person has rung, how many garbage cans they've delivered.
我看着它从相当原始的政治操作发展到更圆滑一些，并试图给人一种“我们真的很关心这些候选人的资历”的表象。我们想要真正得到律师协会好评且在法官席上表现良好的律师。他们更关注这在公共领域看起来如何。所以他们知道在谈论一个党员有多忠诚、这个人敲了多少门铃、送了多少垃圾桶时要更谨慎一些。
Not that that stops them, he says, from still doing things like Abdon saw them do in 2009, putting in the well-connected Pamela Hill Veal onto the ticket for appellate judge despite a bad bar association rating. And despite being scolded by the very appeals court she was trying to get onto. The one way that the Chicago Party Judicial candidates lack diversity, he says, is that there's still nobody on it without clout.
这并不是说阻止了他们——他说——继续做像阿布顿在2009年看到的那样的事情，让有背景的帕梅拉·希尔·维尔（Pamela Hill Veal）进入上诉法官名单，尽管律师协会的评价很差。尽管被她试图进入的上诉法院训斥。他说芝加哥民主党司法候选人缺乏多样性的一个方面是，那里仍然没有人是没有影响力的。
You can become a judge in Chicago without going through this process. You can simply put your name on the ballot and run against the official Democratic Party candidate. And people do win this way, especially women and people with Irish names. It's such a truism that Irish names win Chicago judicial elections that candidates will actually add a Fitzgerald to their name, which sadly works.
你可以在不经过这个过程的情况下在芝加哥成为法官。你可以简单地把你的名字写在选票上，与官方民主党候选人竞选。人们确实通过这种方式赢了，尤其是女性和有爱尔兰姓氏的人。爱尔兰姓氏赢得芝加哥司法选举是一个众所周知的事实，以至于候选人实际上会把“菲茨杰拉德”（Fitzgerald）加到他们的名字里，遗憾的是这行得通。
James G. Smith lost a judicial election, and then changed his name to James Fitzgerald Smith and won. And the political machine will use this fact to manipulate the ballot, which brings us to another rule to get on the Democratic slate in Chicago. If the party doesn't choose you for the ballot, of course they don't want you running against them. With one exception.
詹姆斯·G·史密斯（James G. Smith）输掉了一场司法选举，然后改名为詹姆斯·菲茨杰拉德·史密斯（James Fitzgerald Smith）并赢了。政治机器会利用这个事实来操纵选票，这引出了在芝加哥进入民主党名单的另一个规则。如果党不选择你进入选票，他们当然不希望你与他们竞选。只有一个例外。
Here's some rules of the game. You're not supposed to run if you're not slated. Unless they ask you to run as a pretend candidate to siphon votes. If you're a woman with an Irish name, and they say, OK, now, I want you to get in this race, but don't do anything, don't campaign. You're just there to siphon the opposition so that our guy wins.
这是游戏的一些规则。如果你没有被提名，你不应该竞选。除非他们要求你作为虚假候选人竞选来分流选票。如果你是一个有爱尔兰姓氏的女性，他们说：“好的，现在，我要你参加这场竞选，但什么都别做，别去竞选。”你只是在那里分流反对派，这样我们的人就能赢。
Now, this last session that I went to in '09, it was very funny. Because one of the women got up there and apparently she hadn't been well enough briefed that you're not supposed to publicly discuss what they call ballot management. And so, this was a former state's attorney by the name of Barbara Bailey. So she gets up and she's saying that, my father was a judge for over 20 years and he was helpful in getting union backing for the Party. And the committeemen would say, yeah, that's true. And then she says, I think I'd be able to get union backing for all the candidates. I think I can help. But then she kind of commits the faux pas of saying, I did run five years ago for judge. I did run in a race. I was told not to raise money and not to do any campaigning. I didn't. And you're not supposed to publicly talk about that, but she did. She didn't-- [LAUGHTER] Ms. Bailey did not get slated.
现在，我参加的最后一次会议是在09年，这非常有趣。因为其中一位女性站起来，显然她没有被充分告知你不应该公开讨论他们所谓的“选票管理”。所以，这是一位前州检察官，名叫芭芭拉·贝利（Barbara Bailey）。所以她站起来说，我父亲做了20多年法官，他在为党争取工会支持方面很有帮助。党部主任们会说，是的，那是真的。然后她说，我认为我有能力为所有候选人争取工会支持。我想我可以帮忙。但后来她犯了一个外交失误，说：“五年前我也确实竞选过法官。我确实参加过一场比赛。我被告知不要筹款，不要做任何竞选活动。我没做。”你不应该公开谈论那个，但她做了。她没有——[笑声] 贝利女士没有入选。
So she did not get slated again.
所以她再次没入选。
No, she did not get slated again. She was told, OK, be a little bit more discreet next time.
不，她没入选。有人告诉她，下次谨慎一点。
You know, you think of an old boys' network as being sort of shadowy and sinister, but there's something-- like, reading your accounts-- there's something sort of goofy about this. You know what I mean? Like, seeing it up close.
你知道，你认为“老男孩网络”是阴暗而邪恶的，但有一些——阅读你的记述——这其中有些东西……某种程度上很滑稽。你明白我的意思吗？近距离观察它。
Yes, goofy and quaint. It's sort of a vestige that's still there. An important point to make is, there are some very good judges in Cook County. If you're a good lawyer and you want to be a judge, you realize that this is the game you've got to play and you learn how to play it. And you can do it without completely compromising your morals or ethics.
是的，滑稽而古怪。这是一种仍然存在的遗迹。要说明的一点是，库克县有一些非常好的法官。如果你是一名优秀的律师并想成为法官，你会意识到这是你必须玩的游戏，你学会了如何玩它。你可以做到而不会完全损害你的道德。
And there are some judges who have done that, and who have come through the system. The system actually, miraculously, does produce some good judges. But a lot of them will say privately how annoying they find it, having to go through this process of having to kiss the rings of all the committeemen in order to get elected to the bench.
确实有一些法官做到了，并且通过了这个系统。这个系统实际上，奇迹般地，确实产生了一些好法官。但很多人私下里会说，他们觉得为了竞选法官席而必须经过亲吻党部主任戒指的这个过程有多么烦人。
Abdon Pallasch, political reporter for the Chicago Sun-Times. We called 12 judges and former judicial candidates for comment. 11 did not return our calls. One told us he was very grateful to his committeemen. If not for the committeemen, he said, he never would have been able to become a judge.
阿布顿·帕拉斯，《芝加哥太阳报》的政治记者。我们给12位法官和前司法候选人打了电话请求评论。11位没有回电。一位告诉我们，他非常感谢他的党部主任。他说，如果不是党部主任，他永远不可能成为一名法官。
[MUSIC - "GOOD OLD BOYS" BY JOHN HARTFORD]
[音乐 - 约翰·哈特福德（John Hartford）的《Good Old Boys》]
Our program was produced today by Sarah Koenig, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Jane Feltes, Jonathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Eric Mennel. Music help from Jessica Hopper. Seth Lind is our production manager. Emily Condon's our office manager. Jen Berman's filling in as our west coast producer.
我们的节目今天由莎拉·凯尼格（Sarah Koenig）制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、简·费尔特斯（Jane Feltes）、乔纳森·门吉瓦（Jonathan Menjivar）、莉萨·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）共同制作。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。制作协助来自埃里克·门内尔（Eric Mennel）。音乐协助来自杰西卡·霍珀（Jessica Hopper）。赛斯·林德（Seth Lind）是我们的制作经理。艾米丽·康顿（Emily Condon）是我们的办公室经理。詹·伯曼（Jen Berman）担任我们的西海岸制作人。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our show by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia. He's been catching up with his old DVDs of Project Runway. He loves Andre.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播国际分发。WBEZ管理层对我们节目的监督由我们的老板，托瑞·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生负责。他一直在看他的《天桥骄子》（Project Runway）老DVD。他喜欢安德烈（Andre）。
He's a [? barstool, ?] a seamstress. You cut your head open, man, that guy can sew like crazy.
他是个高明的缝合匠。如果你脑袋被割破了，伙计，那家伙缝合的技术简直绝了。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。